ANURAG WADEHRA:
Welcome, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
My name is Anurag Wadehra
with the Google Cloud.
It's a unique occasion
and a privilege
for me to host this
event for Google.
I'll start with a
very simple story.
I grew up in Delhi
in a household
where both my grandparents
were refugees from Pakistan.
So partition was not
dinnertime topic.
In fact, it was a lived reality.
Every day, we talked about an
uncle who didn't quite make it,
an aunt who was lost
somewhere in the journey,
or somebody who lost
their fortune overnight.
These were the tales we grew
up with in our household.
Yet, when we went
to school, there
was nary a mention of
any of these realities.
What we read in textbooks were
the grand history, the leaders,
like Nehru, Jinnah,
Gandhi, Mountbatten,
who saved us or savaged us--
depending upon the side you
were on--
and who delivered
us independence.
All that was completely
contrary to the actual
lived experiences of 10
million people or more
who were displaced by partition.
Fortunately, a lot has
changed in last 20 years.
And I'm here to introduce
two institutions that have
been doing phenomenal work.
The first one is 1947
Partition Archive,
that has been collecting
the stories and testimonies
of the survivors of partition.
And the second institution
is EnActe Arts,
that has been working on some
interesting and creative ways
to bring many of
these stories to life.
So let's begin
with the first set
of guests for the 1947 Archive.
Let's roll with a video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I feel like I'm a
[INAUDIBLE] plant.
[INAUDIBLE] can
be put here, here.
I have no roots.
[LAUGH]
- And I remember my mother made
me sit down, tear all the bed
sheets.
And then I knew why.
Because all these wounded
people who were coming in.
She had converted one place
for clearing their wounds.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
ANURAG WADEHRA: Why don't
we invite the guests?
Please join, three of you.
[APPLAUSE]
Let me do quick introductions
to the unique guests from 1947
Partition Archive.
I have over here
Guneeta Singh Bella,
who is currently the executive
director of 1947 Partition
Archive.
She was born in Delhi and
immigrated with her parents
to US when she was 10.
And during a trip to
Hiroshima in 2008,
she was deeply moved
by the oral histories
of those who survived the
atomic bombing in Japan
and was inspired to begin
recording oral histories
of partition witnesses.
She is a condensed matter
physicist by profession,
and was last seen working
on quantum interfaces
at Berkeley, Lawrence
Berkeley Lab.
In 2013, she began volunteering
full time for the archive.
Today, with nearly
5,000 oral histories
of witnesses from 12
countries have been recorded,
making it the largest
oral history effort
for South Asian subcontinent.
The other two guests are--
[APPLAUSE]
GUNEETA SINGH BELLA: Thank you.
ANURAG WADEHRA: The other two
guests are citizen historians.
And we'll learn more about that.
Reena Kapoor has been a
founding donor to '47 Archive
since the year of its inception.
She became involved
as a citizen historian
after she heard
Guneeta talk about it
at the end of a play
on partition in 2011.
Being a child of partition
refugees herself,
Reena finds her
bliss in interviewing
elders who were witnesses
and survivors to this event.
Professionally, she
makes her living
as a product
management executive
and lives in the Bay Area.
Farhana Afroz is from Bangladesh
and a software test engineer
working in the Bay Area.
She learned about the
'47 Archive from a flyer
at a local grocery store that
read 1947 Partition Archive--
share, collect, and donate.
Her journey with the archive
started as a citizen historian
in 2011.
She has collected over 100
stories personally so far.
She has recorded stories in
US as well as in Bangladesh,
and she is also a
founding donor and a board
member of the Archive.
Welcome to all three of you.
GUNEETA SINGH BELLA: Thank you.
ANURAG WADEHRA: Let me
start with you, Guneeta.
So, tell us about
how this all started
and where did the idea come from
and how did it take this form?
GUNEETA SINGH BELLA: Yeah.
So I come from a
partition-affected family.
My grandparents migrated from
what's now Lahore in Pakistan
to Amritsar in Punjab.
So I had grown up
with those stories.
I come from an army
family-- very familiar
with the India-Pakistan
tensions.
And one of the things
that happened, when I
moved to the US when I was 10.
I went to high school here.
It wasn't even mentioned
in my textbooks.
And I knew it was a big
deal, because I had heard
my grandparents--
hi, [INAUDIBLE]----
I had heard my
grandparents talk about it.
And they had talked
about the millions
of people that were affected.
And so there was
that discrepancy.
When I talked about
it to my teacher,
she said, oh, well,
it must not have
been a big deal, because it's
not mentioned in our textbooks.
So I knew something needed to
be done way back in high school,
I just never knew what.
And the spark came--
the a-ha moment was
in Japan in 2008.
I was in Hiroshima, and
I saw the Peace Memorial,
and I saw the oral
history archives.
And I found them to
be extremely powerful.
And I realized that
those testimonies
gave the bombing of Hiroshima
legitimacy and importance.
And that's kind of
how it was documented.
That's what inspired
the documentation.
That's what we needed
to do [INAUDIBLE]..
ANURAG WADEHRA:
[INAUDIBLE] the slides
you want to show to [INAUDIBLE]
us on some of these incidents?
GUNEETA SINGH BELLA: So yeah,
if you imagine for a second
if Hiroshima had
not been documented
and the Holocaust had
not been documented,
we'd be in a very, very
different world today.
For instance, the UNHCR was
inspired from the work done
with the Holocaust survivors.
And the nuclear
nonproliferation movements
came from the work
done in Hiroshima.
Here's partition by the numbers.
14.5 million people
approximately--
the latest numbers--
migrated in '46 through '48.
About 20,000, if you look
at the next 10 years.
That's about 1% of the world's
population at that time.
So one in 100
people in the world
migrated, became refugees.
ANURAG WADEHRA:
20 million total.
GUNEETA SINGH BELLA: Yeah.
And if you extrapolate to today,
that's going to be 70 million.
That's incredible.
So the number of people
affected-- about 14%
of the world's population, if
you look at the entire South
Asian subcontinent.
People don't think
everything was affected.
Everywhere, there was
impacts of partition.
But from our oral
histories, we know
that every corner
of South Asia saw
some sort of influx or refugees
coming in or out, basically.
We don't even know how many
people died during partition.
I already told you
the Japan story,
so we'll skip this slide.
But ultimately,
what we needed to do
was record as many oral
histories as fast as possible.
And we needed to reach
a diaspora of people
all over the world.
And so we leveraged modern
technology at the time
in 2009, 2010, and we started
to crowdsource oral histories
by teaching people everywhere
how to record stories.
And so we democratized the
recording of South Asia's
history in that way.
And so if you go to our website,
you'll see this Google Map.
So thanks, guys, for whoever
works on Google Maps.
You can check out
some of the stories.
You can click on, say, a city.
You'll see stories from that
city pop up on the right.
And then as you
go further, you'll
see that if you click
on one of the stories,
you can watch a little
snippet of the video.
The full videos
actually are being
stored at Stanford
University Libraries,
and you can access
them there slowly.
And you can see an
excerpt of the story.
The goal is to record
10,000 oral histories.
And together, all of us who are
volunteering to do this work
are going to make that
happen with your support.
So far, we're at 5,000.
We've recorded 5,000 oral
histories, which is already
immense, because it makes it
one of the largest oral history
projects coming
out of South Asia,
and one of the largest
video-based projects
in the world.
So each of those stories
is about two hours.
You can imagine how
much video that is.
About 550 people have
helped record them
from over 300 cities around
the world in 12 countries, 22
languages, and 3/4
of a million people
are following these
stories on social media.
So the stories can also be
found in a number of libraries
across South Asia pretty soon.
That's something we're
working on with Tata Trusts.
So I'm going to go ahead and--
ANURAG WADEHRA: So let me turn
that next question to Reena.
Reena, what's your
connection to partition
and why did you become
a citizen historian?
REENA KAPOOR: Yeah.
So as it has been said
by a couple of you,
my family was also affected
greatly by partition.
Both my parents were
children when the families
were forced to flee from
what was, at the time,
undivided India,
but is now Pakistan.
And my mother's
family, in particular--
my grandmother was a
young widow at the time,
it just so happened.
And she pretty much
fled with four children
and absolutely nothing on her.
And I grew up hearing all these
stories and how many people
were lost and
family members that
lost their lives, lost
their livelihoods,
and any assets that they owned.
My grandmother was sort
of a legend in the family,
also, because she was
one of those people who
got on a train, one of those
legendary trains, which
basically showed up on either
side, on the India side
and also on the Pakistan
side, filled with dead bodies,
because people were massacred.
And she traveled
those trains twice,
once to bring her children
to the India side,
and then the second time to go
back all the way to Peshawar
because they were from that
Northwest frontier, which
even today is a troubled
area, to bring some assets so
that she could
raise her children.
And she actually managed
to do that successfully,
pretending to be a dead
body on those trains.
So for good reason, she
was considered a legend.
And I grew up hearing
these stories.
I also grew up hearing
about a lot of animosity
toward the other side.
And as has been
said before, there
was not much in our textbooks
except for the glorification
of our political leaders.
And the story of partition
that I heard from textbooks--
and there was very little by
way of really accurate history
books at the time--
was very divorced
from the reality
of people on the ground.
And when I grew up, I started
to read various accounts.
And if any of you are interested
in partition, an excellent book
by Urvashi Butalia, which is
"The Other Side of Silence."
She was amongst the first
people to actually record
oral histories.
And her book is based on that.
And when I read that, I
realized that what had happened
to people on the ground was
very different than what
had been sold to the people as
the causality of this event.
And then the second
thing that happened
was when I was in Delhi--
I was in IIT Delhi in first
year, and it was 1984.
And something very
similar happened
at the time, when Indira
Gandhi was assassinated,
the prime minister, and
local people attacked Sikhs.
And willy-nilly mobs appeared.
And there were
murders and rapes.
And a lot of what I had
read about the realities
of partition seemed
to be repeated.
And these incidents and
the history of my family
really troubled me.
So in 2011, as
Anurag mentioned, I
went to watch this
play, [PUNJABI] which
in Punjabi means, if you haven't
seen Lahore, you haven't yet
been born, which is an ode to
the glories of the old Lahore.
And at the end of that--
that play is about partition
and about an old lady who
refuses to leave her ancestral
home after partition,
which was, again, a story
I had heard many times.
And Guneeta, the founder,
spoke about her vision
for the archive.
And I was very impressed.
And I thought this is
exactly the kind of work
I want to volunteer for.
So since I have so much
time from my day job
and being a wife
and mother, I said,
why not put it all to good use
and become a citizen historian?
And I've been doing that.
And it has been my bliss.
ANURAG WADEHRA: So what has
been some of your key insight,
if you'll close off with that?
REENA KAPOOR: So
obviously, there
have been great learning,
just learning from our elders
about what really happened and
where did these mobs come from.
And one of the
questions I get asked
a lot is, who were these
people who chose to kill
and murder and rape and
mutilate each other?
After all, Hindus
and Muslims and Sikhs
had lived together
for centuries.
So what went so radically wrong?
And there are many,
many answers to that.
But I think the
scariest of the answers,
really, is that it
was people like you
and me who chose
to pick up arms,
chose to actually listen to
our very misguided leaders,
and chose to find
differences amongst us when
there were so much in common.
I think if Indians meet
people from Pakistan
and vice versa, I think--
and also Bangladesh, as my
fellow citizen historian--
and I've interviewed people
from Bengal and [INAUDIBLE]..
We find we have more
in common than we
do with the rest of
the world, yet we
find it somehow OK
to be ready to kill
for the sake of our identity.
So the greatest
thing for me has been
how watchful we need to
be about such forces,
and how easy it is
for ordinary people
to turn to violence in
the name of their tribe.
So that has been great.
The other insight
for me has been how
remarkable that generation was.
And [INAUDIBLE],, that's why I'm
such a great admirer of you,
as well.
Partition happened.
These were people who had lived
in their ancestral villages
and cities and homes,
had never even traveled,
had very little idea
of what was India.
They thought they
were living in India.
So what was Pakistan and
what was the new India?
And yet they somehow found
their way to a new life
and just went about surviving
and building their new lives
and providing for their
children and got on with it.
And it speaks to the resilience
and the remarkable nature
of the people at the time.
But I think what the
government ended up
doing was taking that
and allowing history
to be swept under the rug.
And I think that is something
that we should not allow to do,
because this is a history
that has repeated itself
and will continue
to repeat itself.
And as Guneeta
mentioned, the animosity
between India and
Pakistan-- here
are two nations that
still can't get past it.
They're sitting there with
nuclear missiles pointed
at each other.
And we ought to do what we can,
even if it is by bringing forth
accounts of the people who
have suffered to inform
the rest of us that just
like the violence is
within our power,
so is the peace.
ANURAG WADEHRA: Thank you.
Very well said.
So I want to turn to Farhana.
Farhana, you have a unique
perspective, particularly
the work you've been
doing with Bengal.
And Bengal often
gets less coverage
when it comes to the
topic of partition.
It has its unique history
related to partition.
Can you share with us
some salient points
about that, Bangladesh?
FARHANA AFROZ: Thank you.
Thank you for the kind
introduction at the beginning.
Anurag said that I
am from Bangladesh.
But when people ask
me where are you from,
I actually tell them my
grandmother is from India.
My mother was born in Pakistan,
and I was born in Bangladesh.
And that's all in the
same land, Bengal.
And even though none of my
family members had to migrate
and we know we did not
go through the sufferings
that your families did, but
our family has seen partition.
And there is a profound effect--
hence the identity has
changed over the years.
When I first saw that flyer
about 1947 in that grocery
store, the first thing
that went through my mind
was, what took them so long?
And later I found
out, it's not them.
It's actually her.
So I got involved with
the Partition Archive.
I got trained as a
citizen historian.
And I started recording stories
in the Bay Area, primarily.
Then I went to other cities
in the United States.
And then I went to
Bangladesh, actually, in 2012.
I traveled to Bangladesh for
a month to collect stories.
When you hear the Bengal
side of the partition,
most people think, the Hindus
of East Pakistan migrated
to Kolkata, and the Muslims of
Kolkata migrated to Bangladesh,
and that's about it.
But that is definitely
a major portion
of the partition
on the Bengal side.
But there is another
side of the story that
are about the forgotten people.
A lot of people migrated
from Bihar and Uttar Pradesh,
Meghalaya, and Assam in 1947.
They migrated to the
nearest part of Pakistan,
which was East Pakistan
and Bangladesh today.
So what happened is these people
were Urdu-speaking people,
moved to East Pakistan, and it
was Pakistan and it was good.
But in 24 years in 1971, East
Pakistan became Bangladesh.
During the Liberation
War of Bangladesh,
the Urdu-speaking community,
which was about 170,000 people
at that time, sided
with the Pakistani army,
because they wanted to
keep one big Pakistan.
As it became Bangladesh,
now these people
are kind of outsiders.
They wanted to go to Pakistan.
They want to migrate
to West Pakistan.
Pakistan, which
is a new country--
West Pakistan, I mean--
was not ready to take such a
big refugees, 170,000 people.
So they were left in Bangladesh
in the land of Bengal.
And the Geneva
Convention put them
in different refugee
camps in 1972
so that they are not
attacked and they're safe.
When I went to
Bangladesh in 2012,
I found out there are 167
refugee camps in Bangladesh.
And those Urdu-speaking
people are still
living in those camps.
Nobody has come for them.
Nobody is willing to take them.
And since they
sided with Pakistan
and they identified
themselves as Pakistanis,
the Bangladesh government
was not taking them, either.
So these were refugees.
And they were living in refugee
camps for 40-plus years.
They were given a
8-by-10 room in 1972,
so maybe the family was
husband and wife and a child.
But by the time, in 2012,
42 years have passed,
their family has grown.
And they're still living
in that 8-by-10 room.
And nobody is
talking about them.
They're not citizens of
Pakistan or Bangladesh.
They are basically stateless.
So this has been going
on for a very long time.
And a lot of people, especially
the Urdu-speaking community,
they basically
want their rights.
So in 2008, fortunately,
the Bangladesh government
ruled that people who
were born after 1971, that
means in Bangladesh the children
who were born in Bangladesh,
will be granted the
citizenship of Bangladesh.
Can you go to the
next slide, please?
OK.
So this is one family
that I interviewed.
The lady who is second from
right, her name is Mrs.
[? Khairun ?] [? Nisa. ?]
She walked from Bihar in 1947
because there was a
huge riot in Bihar.
We all heard about it.
The lady to her right
is her daughter.
She was 16 days old.
She was holding her daughter and
walked all the way from Bihar
to East Pakistan.
And they settled.
And then she had other children,
her two other daughters.
But by the time 1971 happened,
now they are stateless.
So this is actually a room
in Geneva camp in Dhaka,
where they still live.
This whole family lives there.
Fortunately, their grandson,
who is not pictured here,
who is 22 years old, was granted
citizenship of Bangladesh,
because he was born after '72.
So this was the highlight
of my trip to Bangladesh.
I did interview a lot of
people, 60 stories almost,
but these stories
of the refugee camps
really stayed with
me, because these are
the people who are forgotten.
Slowly, they're
getting their rights.
But they are really
stateless people to this day.
Mrs. [? Khairun ?] [? Nisa ?]
doesn't have citizenship.
ANURAG WADEHRA: Very
powerful and very sad story.
Thank you for sharing that.
Just in closing, can
you please share with us
some insights you have
from the work you've
been doing after 70
years of partition,
if you could
summarize that for us?
GUNEETA SINGH BELLA: Yeah, sure.
Can I share a couple of slides?
So these are just
anecdotes from stories.
So these stories--
one of the cool things
is not only do you
learn about partition,
but you learn about
pre-partition culture, cultures
that are now becoming obsolete.
So here's a gentleman we had
interviewed, actually, right
here in Rodeo in the Bay Area.
He was 107 at the time.
He's not alive any longer.
But he told me this one
story that really stood out.
So we think of chai as a very
staple South Asian drink.
But he told me about
a time in the 1920s
when they used to boycott chai
because they were boycotting
the East India
Company that they felt
was trying to popularize
tea in an area
where people didn't drink tea
in a lot of northern India.
And he claimed that
they used to go
around spiking people's milk.
I mean, I don't know
how true that is,
but that was the
rumor of the time.
And so he, to this
day, did not drink tea.
So I thought that
was fascinating.
But of course, in
terms of partition,
he did walk for miles
and miles all the way
from North-West Frontier region
over to what's now India.
Another impact of partition
was art and culture.
So here's a photograph of a
music family, a music gharana.
So a lot of music
gharanas were disrupted
when musicians had to
up and leave and leave
behind a lot of their art.
And for instance, there's
a popular story of--
there's certain
musical families that
used to perform in the
Golden Temple in Punjab.
And they now live in Pakistan.
And they're not able
to perform any longer
because they live on the
other side of the border--
so fascinating histories
like that of disruption.
We're also-- and by accident--
recording endangered languages.
So there's a language
called [? Toregali, ?] and
there's a number of
stories now in the archive
because a volunteer from
the North-West Frontier
region in Swat who
speaks that language
decided to record stories of
his elders in that language.
And there's not many
other recordings, if any,
in that language.
Another thing that
really stands out
when you record oral
histories is the significance
of the kingdoms pre-partition,
which today have been
mostly swept under the rug.
So there was British India,
which is the pink region
that you see on this map.
And then the darker region
consists of about 560 kingdoms.
And so [INAUDIBLE].
ANURAG WADEHRA:
Thank you so much.
I want to close off in one
short video that sums up
the observations, if I may.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Yes, I was named Keerti.
My father used to
call me, [INAUDIBLE]..
You see, [INAUDIBLE] My father
believed in all religions.
My sister who was older
to me, [INAUDIBLE] We
used to celebrate [INAUDIBLE].
We used to celebrate
[INAUDIBLE]..
Then every year, my father
and my two brothers,
they went to the
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
was brought [INAUDIBLE] We used
to have [INAUDIBLE] We always
went for [INAUDIBLE].
- OK.
- [INAUDIBLE] I remember
all three religions being
celebrated in my house.
[TYPEWRITER KEYS CLICKING]
And I was 11 and a half.
And my sister, elder sister, who
was not married was around 18.
We left Pakistan.
So we had a very, very
[INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE] there--
S-O museum S dash O dash museum.
And the owner of
that was a Muslim.
My father left the keys
with him like that.
And he says,
everything is yours.
You look after it.
I'm coming back.
And he was so genuine.
And he was so faithful.
He sent back all our
stuff and sent it
to our uncle, who was
in the [? army. ?]
[END PLAYBACK]
ANURAG WADEHRA: So I'm going
to thank you, for three of you
to join us.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
GUNEETA SINGH BELLA: Thank you.
ANURAG WADEHRA: So I want
to switch gears a little bit
and talk about the
second project,
which is equally interesting--
a different mood,
a different turn.
I've had the pleasure of getting
to know EnActe Arts, which is
a South Asian theater company.
And I would like to invite the
founder and artistic director
of EnActe Arts on stage.
She's Vanita Sud Belani.
Please welcome her.
[APPLAUSE]
As I transition out, I was
impressed by one statement
in your mission--
VINITA SUD BELANI: OK.
ANURAG WADEHRA: --which I
thought was very interesting,
which said, the borders that
separate us are political,
but the ties that
bind us are cultural.
I thought that summed up
your mission quite well.
Thank you.
VINITA SUD BELANI: Thank you.
Thank you, Anurag,
and a very special
thank you Anurag for
arranging this Talk at Google.
We are in such august company.
So if the archive is the
repository of stories,
then EnActe and
Noorani Dance, who
is our co-conspirator
in this project,
we are the tellers of stories.
We tell stories through
dance, through music.
I hope you noticed
the music that
was playing in the
beginning when you came in
and when you sat down.
That was Raginder
Singh Momi, who
is the music composer of
the play, the part that I'm
going to talk about.
I have here several
actors, directors
who are part of EnActe.
What does EnActe do?
We tell stories.
We create contemporary
theatrical storytelling
projects that start
conversations,
that start conversations about
our history, about our culture,
about our religions, and
essentially about our place
as South Asians in
global society today.
We are the people who--
because we are in America,
we are an immigrant community
in America--
we create a platform that
allows the next generation
to embrace who they are
and where they came from
and give them the tools to
create a new culture that
is an amalgamation of the
culture that they came from
and the land that
they live in now.
So that's EnActe Arts.
We do theatrical projects.
Noorani Dance has
the same mission,
but they do it through dance.
The founder of Noorani Dance
is in Pakistan right now.
She is born and brought
up in the Bay Area.
Her name is Farah
Yasmeen Shaikh.
And she is, as we speak,
performing a dance piece
on the story on the life
of Noor Jahan in Lahore,
where Noor Jahan was buried.
So we not only
create stories here,
we take them back to
where they belong.
There's a few things about us
as a South Asian population
in the diaspora out of
our own South Asian roots.
The South Asians
in the Bay Area--
we tend to follow the
three gods of education.
And the three gods of education
are doctor, lawyer, engineer.
[LAUGHTER]
Some of us have a
[? kick in the step. ?]
However, following the three
gods of education-- doctor,
lawyer, engineer-- means that
we have become a model minority
in countries like the US.
We behave ourselves.
We own a fair amount of money.
We look good on paper.
What we don't stop
to think about
is that the children that
are born to these three gods
are not necessarily using the
same filter that was applied
to the people who came here.
They're a normal population.
So there are as many
dancers, actors, artists,
playwrights amongst
this population
as there are in any
other normal population.
And who is serving that need?
Well, that is us.
So what do we do?
In the environment
that we live in,
there are three kinds of
storytellers that we have--
the professional storytellers.
There is Kunal in
the background here.
There he is, Kunal.
He's a professional actor.
He is making his way.
He is an integral
part of EnActe.
He actually works at EnActe.
He's our marketing manager.
He's a professional actor.
And talk to him about his story.
That's one kind of storyteller.
There is a second
kind of storyteller
that is a wannabe, somebody
who wants to be in the arts
but needs the training.
Then there is a third kind
of performer, actor, theater
person who we call the
second career person.
That's the Googlers
in the room who,
in their copious amounts of free
time, go into community theater
somewhere.
So EnActe is one of the only
theater companies in the US,
that actually caters to
all three kinds of talents.
We have aspire productions
for community theaters.
We have hybrid productions.
And we have professional
productions.
Our professional productions
tend to be large.
We collaborate with a lot of
people, especially musicians
and dancers, because in
the South Asian tradition
of storytelling, it's
almost impossible
to tell the story without the
dance and the music associated
with the flavor of that story.
So I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about "The Parting,"
which is a play which tells
the story of the partition.
Guneeta and all the
citizen historians
have done such an incredible
job of capturing these stories.
It is now our job to bring these
stories to where all of you
are.
And as they mentioned, the
stories, the historic accuracy
of that period does not
come from the political
and the party line briefs
that were given to us.
The British cannot
write that story.
[INAUDIBLE] cannot
That story is written by
the people who experienced,
who stepped across that line
that was made in such a hurry
and found themselves in their
own country to be refugees.
That's the story
we want to tell.
But today, I am
going to tell you
a story that sort of
encapsulates everything
that we're trying to do.
And I want to bring on stage a
very special person, Mr. Ravi
Chopra.
[APPLAUSE]
RAVI CHOPRA: [INAUDIBLE]
VINITA SUD BELANI: Ravi
ji is very special to us.
He has been an actor with
us for a very long time.
I am not going to give an
introduction to Ravi ji.
We are just going to jump
straight into his story.
And you're going to
know why as we talk.
So Ravi ji, tell me, when
and where were you born?
RAVI CHOPRA: Vinita, I was
born in very famous place known
all over the world,
Lahore, in the year 1938.
VINITA SUD BELANI: 1938.
So you were about
eight and a half,
almost nine, when
partition happened.
RAVI CHOPRA: Yeah.
VINITA SUD BELANI: So where
were you living at that time?
RAVI CHOPRA: I was living with
my grandmother and my younger
brother in a village
known as [INAUDIBLE]..
It was then a small village.
Today, it may be a big town.
VINITA SUD BELANI:
And when in 1947--
what were you doing
there in the village?
RAVI CHOPRA: So I used to go
to [INAUDIBLE],, the school,
and learn Urdu from a Maulvi--
Maulvi means teacher--
and lead a normal life.
My father was the in charge
police station [INAUDIBLE]..
He got his orders for
promotion to the next track.
That is [? sub-inspector. ?]
And he had to go to [INAUDIBLE]..
So he left us under the
care of one local merchant,
[INAUDIBLE],, to look
after us in his absence.
And that he would come back
in a month and a half or so,
and he would take us to India.
My mother and sister, they
had already gone to India.
So that was the kind of
scenario at that time.
VINITA SUD BELANI: OK.
So what made you
leave [INAUDIBLE]??
RAVI CHOPRA: As I
mentioned, we were leading
just normal life, no worries.
We were small kids--
going to school, coming back,
playing with the friends.
And then one fine
morning, the [INAUDIBLE]
of the police station, that's
number two of the police
station.
He came to [INAUDIBLE]
and warned him
that his host is going to
be attacked that night.
and so he should leave
as soon as possible.
He took it seriously.
And he collected
all his valuables--
cash, jewelry,
important documents.
And many of them,
even, they tried
to hide it under the
clothing, all over the body.
And when the darkness came,
we went to the [INAUDIBLE]
railway station.
This was a village,
only passenger trains
would stop there.
So this [INAUDIBLE],, I think
that he rightly thought that
if we get the passenger train,
it's going to stop at every
station, which was very--
it was not safe, very risky.
So he went the opposite
direction, to a junction town,
[INAUDIBLE].
From there, we got
the [INAUDIBLE] train
so that we don't have to stop.
We only stop at the
junction station
and not at every
village station.
VINITA SUD BELANI:
So when you were
going in the opposite
direction, you
must have passed
[INAUDIBLE] village.
RAVI CHOPRA: Yes.
We passed through
the Kasur village.
And [INAUDIBLE] was sitting
right next to the window.
And I distinctly remember
him shouting, [INAUDIBLE]
And we also [INAUDIBLE] we
saw fire almost everywhere
in our village where
we were staying.
And he was literally
in tears when
he reached the next
junction station [INAUDIBLE]
from where we were to catch
the train to India [INAUDIBLE]..
VINITA SUD BELANI: So what
happened on arrival in station,
then?
RAVI CHOPRA: [INAUDIBLE]
you see, this place,
when we are waiting
for the train--
because trains had no timings.
There's no timetable sheet.
That train will
come in yesterday,
the train will come today.
That kind of
scenario [INAUDIBLE]..
So we were just
waiting for the train.
And then suddenly
the firing started.
And all the people
on the platform,
we started running
to find the cover.
And in the process, a
bullet hit me on my calf
and I started bleeding.
And then my [INAUDIBLE],,
very courageous lady
with a good presence
of mind, she
thought of her [? duties. ?]
Sterilize with her urine,
and made it a
bandage on my wound.
And we were hiding
behind a pillar.
VINITA SUD BELANI: And did
you make it onto the train?
RAVI CHOPRA: Yes,
we did, but when
the train came, as you
see on the pictures here,
it was fully packed, people
sitting on the top of the roof,
even in the couplings
of the trains,
people sitting in
front of the engine.
And the compartments
were totally packed.
And the people on
the platform, you
can just imagine [INAUDIBLE].
There's no place to getting
them still, trying to find place
in all that confusion.
We were fortunate in the
sense that [INAUDIBLE]
had known the assistant
station master [INAUDIBLE]..
And he paid him a lot of
cash and money, because he
had a first-class
compartment reserved to him,
his family traveling to Kasur.
Kasur was a border town
next to [INAUDIBLE]..
So it was a border
town on Pakistan-India.
And that was the only
way we could survive.
So he paid whatever
he wanted so that we
could be part of his family.
VINITA SUD BELANI: And so you
got onto the train with him?
RAVI CHOPRA: Yes.
I had an assistant station
masters' family, a wife
and, I think, two small kids,
[INAUDIBLE] family, myself,
my younger brother,
my [INAUDIBLE]..
So we all went [INAUDIBLE] into
the first-class compartment.
And--
VINITA SUD BELANI: What do
you remember of that journey?
What do you remember?
Were there stops?
And between stops--
RAVI CHOPRA: Stops, yes,
from [INAUDIBLE] to Kasur
there were, if I remember, two
or three stops, [INAUDIBLE]
stops, the train would stop.
And at every stop,
there would be
mobs of people coming
when the train stopped
and just shouting [INAUDIBLE]
You see, they used [INAUDIBLE]..
Because from India's
side, the Sikhs were--
[INAUDIBLE] the Sikhs were
massacring the Muslim people.
And they used to
shout on [INAUDIBLE]
trying to find if any Sikh
families, [INAUDIBLE]..
And our station master, he
would just open the windows.
He said, no, I'm
the station master.
I am traveling here
with my family.
And we used to hide ourselves in
the bottom and lock ourselves.
[INAUDIBLE] the
first-class compartment
had the bottom attached.
Even until very recently,
we had the bottom attached.
And that is what
[INAUDIBLE] saved us.
Because he would only show his
family, his wife and children.
And he had a beard.
And I still remember that small
beard and kind face, because
of him that we lived, too.
VINITA SUD BELANI: So you
were saved by a kind Muslim.
You were very fortunate.
RAVI CHOPRA: Yes, absolutely.
You can say that
[INAUDIBLE] And maybe
I had to survive
because one day I
had to serve my country
in the rank of general
of the Indian army.
VINITA SUD BELANI: General
RAVI CHOPRA: Yes.
VINITA SUD BELANI: All right.
RAVI CHOPRA: That was
a different story.
VINITA SUD BELANI: OK.
So we'll come back
to this story.
What did you see between stops?
Did you look out of the window?
Did you have the courage
to look out of the window?
RAVI CHOPRA: As we
approaching the platform--
as you were traveling
to look out the window,
you would see young
girls running and jumping
into the wells, young people
with murderous eyes chasing
them.
And they're trying
to save their honor,
no option but to kill
themselves, burn themselves.
And there's a fire
all over the field.
I mean, there was
terrible scenes.
We were not sure what
all is happening.
It's only in retrospect
that they told us.
And so this [INAUDIBLE] even
on the platform, [INAUDIBLE]
you could see the bodies
decorated along the railroad
track, literally lined up.
So that was the kind of
human behavior at that time.
VINITA SUD BELANI:
And what was happening
inside the compartment?
Where you huddled in and--
RAVI CHOPRA: I mean,
as I mentioned,
as far as we were
concerned, thanks
to this assistant
station master,
that he would every
time, he would save us,
because we'd hide out in the
bottom, lock ourselves in.
Only he would be visible.
And even the mob will
come, peek through,
make sure that there's
nobody else and go.
VINITA SUD BELANI: So
when you reached Kasur,
that was the last stop
before the border?
RAVI CHOPRA: Yes.
VINITA SUD BELANI:
What happened then?
RAVI CHOPRA: Yes.
Kasur-- when we reached Kasur,
this assistant station master,
he opened the window and made
sure that everything's OK.
Then he told his family
to get off the train.
And he was going to
say bye bye to us.
Then [INAUDIBLE] told him,
please don't leave us now.
Let the train move.
And let the train move, and
then only, you please leave.
And he did that.
I distinctly remembered
moving train,
he jumped up almost toward
the end of the platform.
And then waved at us.
That kind of picture, I
still have in my mind.
VINITA SUD BELANI:
What a kind man.
And so you crossed the
border and you arrived at--
RAVI CHOPRA: Yes.
And I owe my life to two
Muslim Pakistani gentlemen.
One [INAUDIBLE] who saved us,
[INAUDIBLE] assistant station
master, otherwise I
wouldn't be here today.
VINITA SUD BELANI: Well,
we honor those two people
who saved your life.
We are very happy that
you are here today.
Tell us what happened when
you crossed the border
and arrived at [INAUDIBLE].
RAVI CHOPRA: When we
reached [INAUDIBLE],,
we came out of the compartment.
Believe me, there's blood
splattered on the [INAUDIBLE],,
on the train compartment,
the train we were traveling,
mutilated bodies, hands
hanging from the windows.
This was terrible.
So we were-- as I remember,
we were the only family
survived the massacre.
There was nobody else.
VINITA SUD BELANI: Incredible.
RAVI CHOPRA: And when you think
about the Sikh families who
took care of us,
giving us milk, fruit,
[INAUDIBLE] medical aid,
and that kind of scenario
was there.
And then from there we boarded
the train to go to Delhi.
VINITA SUD BELANI: So you went
to Delhi because you had family
in Delhi, or--
RAVI CHOPRA: Because that
was the only place to go.
VINITA SUD BELANI:
So what happened
when you arrived at Delhi?
RAVI CHOPRA: Delhi
railroad station,
when we arrived,
it was jam packed.
Platform was full of people.
There was hardly
place even to move.
So my grandmother,
holding my son,
I'm limping with my leg hurt.
My younger brother had a fever,
so he's also tagging along.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
my brother got lost.
VINITA SUD BELANI:
Oh, my goodness.
RAVI CHOPRA: And I tell
you, my grandmother,
shouting [INAUDIBLE]
brown hairs.
Have you seen it?
I was also shouting,
[INAUDIBLE],, because, I mean,
just imagine having
suffered all the ordeal
coming back to the destiation
and then again losing
my brother, whom I love so much.
I was in tears.
And they didn't know what to do.
So there, luckily, I found him.
[CRYING]
VINITA SUD BELANI: Sorry.
You found him.
RAVI CHOPRA: Yes.
Sitting, crying.
I hugged him.
VINITA SUD BELANI: Sorry.
So from Delhi station,
where did you go?
RAVI CHOPRA: We
had nowhere to go,
because my [INAUDIBLE]
didn't only remember that
my [INAUDIBLE] name is
[INAUDIBLE] and she's there
somewhere in [INAUDIBLE] and
that my [INAUDIBLE] has got
a [? luggage ?] [? shop ?]
somewhere in [INAUDIBLE]..
That's the only thing we knew.
So we tagged along with
[INAUDIBLE] to the refugee
camp in Karol Bagh.
Those who have seen
Karol Bagh of today,
there was nothing [INAUDIBLE]
or that shopping center.
It was total bare land.
That is where we had
that refugee camp.
And that is where we stayed.
And my [INAUDIBLE] would go
in the morning to [INAUDIBLE]
and find out from every
[? luggage ?] [? shop, ?] do
you know [INAUDIBLE]?
Do you know [INAUDIBLE]?
She's my [INAUDIBLE].
VINITA SUD BELANI:
Amazing woman.
RAVI CHOPRA: Yeah.
So then one morning,
the gentleman
said, yes, that's the name
of my wife, [INAUDIBLE]..
And then he said is [? this ?]
younger sister's [INAUDIBLE]??
My mother's name is [INAUDIBLE].
He said yes.
And then my [INAUDIBLE]
was literally in tears
and introduced
herself and told her
that I have brought
his children here.
And that same evening,
my [INAUDIBLE]
and my cousin's sister
came to the refugee camp
and took us in a
[INAUDIBLE] to her home.
And [INAUDIBLE]
And we were in rags,
stinking clothes.
So we changed, and we
got the new clothes.
And then [INAUDIBLE] I ask you
a question, just what would
be your feeling as
a mother when you
know the children you are taken
as dead have arrived safely?
All mothers, just put
yourself in that situation.
How did my mother
take that news?
That is two first-born who were
taken as dead have arrived.
VINITA SUD BELANI: Incredible.
RAVI CHOPRA: [INAUDIBLE] this is
kind of story for [INAUDIBLE]----
VINITA SUD BELANI: I
can't begin to imagine
how your mother must feel.
RAVI CHOPRA: From what Guneeta
and [INAUDIBLE] told us,
so many [INAUDIBLE]
were massacred.
Millions were disturbed and
affected, badly affected,
just kind of--
and thanks to 1947
Archive that these things
are being compiled.
And I was one of
the first of one.
Guneeta came and
recorded my story.
VINITA SUD BELANI: That's--
well, you're a first
in many ways, Ravi ji.
But in your whole story,
you haven't told us
about your father.
What happened to him?
RAVI CHOPRA: My
father, as mentioned,
had gone to [INAUDIBLE].
So from there, he checked
up the [INAUDIBLE]
so that we have
left [INAUDIBLE]..
But he didn't know what
happened after that.
His influence with the
police and the help of army,
he flew to Delhi.
But [INAUDIBLE] we are putting
that in our "Parting" play.
Everybody used to be
glued to the radio station
to know about
their kith and kin,
say whether they are alive.
Where are they?
Because even from the camp's
announcement used to be there.
Radio stations all
the time, 24 hours,
who are looking for this son?
Was somebody looking
for a mother, somebody
looking for the father?
For 24 hours, a radio station
broadcast would be there.
That is how my father learned
that we have reached India,
but we didn't know where he is.
So it is only when he
came to Delhi that we
got to united as a family.
VINITA SUD BELANI: Incredible.
RAVI CHOPRA: And we all met
in a place, [INAUDIBLE],,
where my grandfather was the
manager of a sugar mills.
VINITA SUD BELANI: Sugar mills.
RAVI CHOPRA: [INAUDIBLE]
sugar mills, yes.
VINITA SUD BELANI: So my
father also moved from Lahore
to Amritsar.
And my grandfather was also the
manager of the sugar mill in
[INAUDIBLE].
We were destined to
meet no matter what.
We're all part of family.
So thank you so much
for sharing that story.
I just--
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE] The reason
we bring up this story
is because Ravi ji,
as he mentioned,
was one of the first people
interviewed by the archive.
His story is one of the earliest
recorded in the archive.
He had an entire
career in the army
and retired as a Major General.
And then he started a second
career here in the Bay Area.
Tell us about that one.
RAVI CHOPRA: You see, when
I came to the United States,
nobody would take
me as a general.
[LAUGHTER]
So I chose my next best passion.
Even when I was in service,
I used to write plays--
small skits, not plays--
skits, act in plays.
And when I grew up in
rank, then my priorities
changed, because I had other
things to take care of.
But the passion remained.
So when I came here, this
was my second best career,
which I thought I would join.
I joined dancing groups.
I joined a theater group
with [INAUDIBLE],, with you.
And one of [INAUDIBLE].
VINITA SUD BELANI:
So I just want
to tell everybody that in
the play that we are doing
about the partition,
which is made up
of true-life accounts
of people like Ravi ji,
he is actually playing the role
of a very kind and benevolent
Muslim Pakistani.
RAVI CHOPRA: In that role,
I'm reliving my partition life
in this role, because
here, also, I'm performing
the role of a Muslim gentlemen.
There, the Muslim saved
my life as Hindus.
Here as a Muslim, I'm
saving Hindus' life.
I'm one of them.
[APPLAUSE]
VINITA SUD BELANI: Thank you.
Thank you so much, Ravi ji.
RAVI CHOPRA: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE]..
VINITA SUD BELANI: So it was an
honor to have Ravi ji on stage
with us and sharing his story.
I just wanted to
bring him onstage
because I wanted to
show what the power is
of a story told in real time
between people and making
that connect.
And these are the stories
that we are telling
in the play about the parting.
There is music and
dance and a lot
of audio-visual, very
high-tech elements in there.
But fundamentally,
these are the stories
that make up the real
history of the partition.
And so I want to
now introduce you
to the person who is the writer
and the director of the play
and let him talk about
the play himself.
My great honor to welcome
on stage, Salil Singh.
[APPLAUSE]
I am not going to
introduce Salil.
His words are going to be
so mesmerizing that you're
going to look him up on Google
as soon as you get out of here.
So take it away, Salil.
SALIL SINGH: Thank you, Vinita.
Several years ago,
as I became familiar
with the work of
the archive, I began
to work on a script for a play
that would dramatize stories
embedded in the experience of
partition, stories of lives
deeply, irreversibly redirected,
torn as a consequence of lines
drawn on a map.
I realized quickly
several important things.
First, it's an immense
subject matter played out
on a vast canvas
of a subcontinent,
and that a terrible silence
has engulfed these stories
across the decades--
a silence that has perpetuated
through a combination
of regret, guilt,
shame, loss, trauma,
incomprehensible suffering,
destruction, and death.
And finally, there is
a brief window of time
in which it is still possible
to gather people on a stage
and in an audience as they have
a living memory of this event.
And it's our chance to speak
across generations and nations,
religions and divisions.
So this was my mandate.
I began to write
a play that would
unlock some of these stories.
The play is called
"The Parting."
And I'll really talk to
you about how it begins.
It begins in a
deserted wasteland
in which characters
are sleeping all
across the expanse of the stage.
Through it walk a young
girl and her grandmother.
The young girl dares
to ask a question which
will awaken the ghosts
of these stories buried
in the fog of history.
And her question is, I want to
know what happened that year.
All across this landscape,
whispers begin to surface.
At first, they're warnings.
They don't wish to be awakened.
These are ghosts who are
very happy living undercover.
1947, 1947.
Why remember?
Let sleeping dogs
lie, or you will hear
them howling through the night.
Who cares to know?
Who dares to name it?
Too much time has gone by.
No one can even remember.
We have tried so hard to forget.
Some things are
better left forgotten.
1947.
If you do, it'll be too
much, too little, too late.
It's too far.
It's too long.
Too many have suffered.
Too many have died.
Too many that lived who
would rather have died.
1947.
If you try to
remember, you will rake
the coals and fan the flames.
But the girl asks, "if
you don't remember,
how will I know who I am?"
And all the whispers
stop at that moment.
This is the key that unlocks
the rest of the play.
So this is what I had for a
shape, a structure, to a play.
It was waiting to meet a
visionary producer, Vinita,
a theater company,
EnActe, which was
ready to take a very huge risk
and put this out there, a dance
theater company, Noorani Dance,
under Farah Yasmeen Shaikh, who
were inspired enough to join
forces and, in some ways,
give me this amazing,
in some ways,
humbling and
ennobling experience
of spearheading this project.
The production is
in full swing, and I
invite you all to
come see it when
it does open in the Bay Area.
What I'd like to
do at this point,
though, is to bring
back on stage Anurag.
You have known him as your
gracious host for this morning.
He's also my story
development collaborator,
who has helped me understand
what stories to tell,
what kinds of
narratives to weave back
into this play that would dare
to paint an image of a moment
in time, which is grand
enough, satisfying enough,
honest enough, brutal
enough to do justice
to this moment in history.
Anurag, will you
speak a word about how
you came to select the
kinds of stories that
have become a part of the play?
ANURAG WADEHRA: Yes.
Thank you.
I have been passionate
about the subject.
In the last 20 years, I
have been collecting stories
and curating stories and also
writing some short stories
on the matter, since it's a
subject was close to my heart.
And when I was invited to
participate in this project,
I realized that through the
support of Vinita and EnActe
as well as direction,
what was possible
was to cherry pick some
of the stories that
could shape the telling of
such a massive incident.
And we deliberately
chose stories
from a variety of sources.
Some of these are obviously
imaginative stories
created by me and others
over the years based
on lived experience
of millions of people.
Some of these are
actually ripped
from the headlines of that era.
For example, a story which is
the centerpiece of the play
is star-crossed lovers of
Zainab and Butta Singh.
Butta Singh was a Sikh
farmer who gave shelter
to a Muslim woman, and who,
after many years of living
together, she was forcibly
sent back to Pakistan,
and how he crossed the
boundaries of religion
and state to get to
reunite with her.
That's a true story.
It was popular at it's time--
very contested.
Another that example
is a story that
was curated from
historical archives--
a story of a British army
limb fitter, [INAUDIBLE],,
who was actually shuttling
between India and Pakistan
armies for almost
a decade or more
and not being able to
reconcile whether he
was a Pakistani or an
Indian [INAUDIBLE]..
And that was the
true story straight
from research that was done by
many scholars as an example.
Yet another story around
how a brother is trying
to protect the honor of
his sister and the price he
has to pay for doing that,
and the kind of question
he faces that.
That's an imagined story from
experiences of many people.
And finally, stories of
Hindu and Muslim neighbors
that we kind of reconstructed
from historical narratives that
talk about how could neighbors
who were living together,
Hindus and Muslims, lose
trust in each other suddenly?
And what would it take
to bring the trust back?
Was it even possible?
So these were some
of the stories
that we kind of
compiled together.
None of these were
selected with the intention
of horror or shock,
although many of them
are horrifying and shocking.
We selected them
from a wide variety
to represent the range
of possible experiences.
Ultimately, the idea was to
ask the question that Salil
had put in the beginning.
Why did this happen?
And how do we make sense of it?
So that was the intention
of these stories.
Thank you.
SALIL SINGH: Pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]
So you can expect a poetic
rendering of these stories
when you come to
see "The Parting"--
something that combines poetry,
dance, theater, acting, words,
and beautiful music.
I would like to
invite at this point
two young ladies who've been
waiting very patiently, Mira
and Athena.
They are part of Noorani Dance.
Let me clarify.
What they're about
to share with you
is a little performance piece.
It's not from the
production of "The Parting."
It is their way of connecting
to the stories and the material
and the events around 1947.
And they've been working on it
as a dance interpretive piece.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: The train to
Lahore was very difficult.
The train stopped at
multiple locations.
And at one point, we'd
looked out the broken windows
to see the train
surrounded by people
with weapons in their hands,
ready to slaughter us,
the passengers.
The train driver managed
to negotiate with the mob
and found a way for the
train and the passengers
to reach its destination safely.
When we arrived, we
saw bloody train cars
and learned that some
of our dearest friends
had been killed on the way.
We arrived at the
crowded station,
carrying whatever we managed to
hold in our arms from our home.
I held to my six-year-old
daughter's hand
with such a tight grasp,
she was complaining.
We pushed through the crowds.
Just as I stepped
onto the train,
I felt my arm being pulled
back by the force of the crowd.
I tried to hold on
with all my strength.
But the grip was loosening,
our sweaty palms not helping,
nor the herd of
people around me.
The train was
starting to move, even
though not all
were on the train,
and even though my daughter
was not on the train.
I never saw her again.
I was 11 years old when
partition was announced.
While we were playing
near the railway station,
we were told that a nearby train
was being attacked by a mob.
We rushed to the tragic
scene, and saw men, women,
and children being
looted and murdered.
Or All we could
hear were screams.
And all we saw were
piles of dead bodies.
I remember seeing a
baby who was still
latched to its dead mother.
Finally, it was our
turn to board the train.
We were stuffed in like
cotton bales in a gunny sack.
The doors of the
train were barricaded
so no one could get out.
The three-day journey was
filled with tribulations.
The train was nearly
massacred just
before the end of the journey.
When we had almost
reached our destination,
a group of insurgents
broke into the train
through one of the
barricaded doors.
Their swords were
covered in a soft cloth.
And they said if the train
going to India comes unharmed,
we will not harm anyone.
Luckily, that train
was not harmed.
When we reached our destination
and we got off the train,
instead of running
for food and water,
people knelt on the ground and
offered prayers of gratitude
that we had made it safely.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
ANURAG WADEHRA: Thank
you, Mira, Athena.
Mira, this morning would not
be complete without inviting
you, as a young person in the
Bay Area, to speak for a moment
about what does it
mean to encounter
these stories, to work with your
art in reconnecting with them?
MIRA: Hello, everyone.
My name is Mira.
I'm 16 years old, and I go to
a high school in Cupertino.
I am one of the
performing members
of Noorani Dance,
founded and directed
by my [INAUDIBLE] teacher,
Farah Yasmeen Shaikh.
I'm fortunate to be one
of the dancers featured
in "The Parting."
As the dance and music
director of "The Parting,"
[INAUDIBLE] wanted to
include other styles
of classical dance, such as
Bharatanatyam and Bengali
and Punjabi folk dances.
These multiple dance forms
represent the diversity
of those that were affected
by the 1947 partition.
With the actors, we will be
weaving different aspects
of real-life events
of the partition
through dance, music,
and a theatrical script.
We hope to represent the
intensity and emotion
of what took place during this
historic time in South Asia.
The partition has
always been puzzling.
How could a man-made
line on a map
displace over 14 million
people and result in the death
of almost 2 million?
South Asians of my
generation often
don't understand the
magnitude of this tragedy.
So taking part in this
project has special meaning
to each of us.
Through this experience,
we have become
more empathetic to the
survivors of the partition.
And we are also more
aware of the history
of tension between
India and Pakistan
and the forces of division
in the world today.
We hope our generation
can learn from this
and change the course of
history towards peace.
Thank you, and I hope to see
you all at "The Parting."
[APPLAUSE]
ANURAG WADEHRA: Thank you
very much for [INAUDIBLE]..
In closing, I want to
thank the panelists
for sharing their work.
I want to thank 1947 Archive
team, Guneeta, Reena,
and Farhana.
And special thanks
to EnActe Arts team
as well, Vinita, as well
as special thanks to Ravi
ji for sharing his experiences.
If any of you are interested
in sharing your time and money,
please, please join us by
donating at Google Give,
directly in the back
or online the website.
And thank you for [INAUDIBLE]
and the production
team of Talks at Google
for supporting this event.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
[APPLAUSE]